comme chaque année les ateliers du
sermac attire les foules
il faut dire qu'à 85 euros l'année
l'adhésion reste abordable
une aubaine pour certains qui souhaitent
découvrir ou perfectionner leurs
connaissances
l'atelier photo par exemple est très
plébiscité je fais de la photo depuis
très longtemps c'est une passion que
j'ai quand j'ai commencé à travailler
mon premier salaire j'ai acheté un
appareil photo mais j'ai toujours fait
en autodidacte et donc comme je suis à
la retraite depuis le 1er août
donc je suis venu pour faire la création
numérique et la photo bien sûr la poche
de la retraite donc je concilie tout ce
que je n'ai pas pu faire à un moment
donc oui je me suis je me lance
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'âge pour se
lancer dans tout ce qui est numérique à
nos bras du tout pas du tout on apprend
on d'un proto le temps 1 des seniors qui
veulent continuer d'apprendre pour se
nourrir l'esprit elie n'hésitent plus à
se tourner vers les nouvelles
technologies est une branche qui va me
mener plus loin mais je commence déjà
par ça et puis par la suite on va voir
si ça m'était laisse jouer moi je vous
je vais continuer ça nous permet de
rester jeunes surtout
et puis des taux fed et de l'évolution
c'est important parce que avec les
petits enfants ou autres il faut
s'accrocher sinon on est vite dépassé le
sermac propose donc un cours qui
s'adapte aux néophytes
on y apprend par exemple graphisme la
restauration de photos ou la sculpture
numérique
le but de l'atelier c'est de vulgariser
des pratiques et donc accessibles des
métiers qu'on pourrait penser assez
hermétique donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment de faire du pas à pas et de
permettre à monsieur madame tout le
monde de s'approprier le nouveau médium
que représente
informatique le sermac offre des
activités variées accessible à tous les
niveaux et toutes les bourses
des ingrédients à l'origine de sa
popularité
mais voilà comme à chaque fois la tente
est à la hauteur du succès des ateliers